two losses in court today for the man
accused of killing an investigative
newspaper reporter in Las Vegas the
defendant Robert
off against murder charges in the
stabbing death of death of order Jeff
gearman a news now investigator Kyle
Payne at this morning's hearing has the
latest on those rulings Kyle you said it
defending himself Robert tell us was in
court this morning arguing two motions
all with no lawyer and after today's
rulings in Clark County District Court
looks like it'll stay that way
Robert tell us r-o-b-e-r-t t-e-l-l-e-s
murder defendant Robert Tellis in court
spelling out his arguments back before
Clark County Judge Michelle Levitt for
the first time since he tried to have
her removed from the case
standby Council standby Council would be
just that on standby in case Telus
needed legal advice as he attempts to
represent himself in his murder trial
for the killing of Las Vegas Review
journal's investigative reporter jeff
gearman which the judge cautioned Telus
against at his last hearing I don't
think anyone ever does a good job
representing themselves but now it's
just himself because the judge ruled
Telus has too many Financial assets to
qualify for the state to pay for his
lawyer he says he currently makes no
income while he's in jail but that he
co-owns a house with his wife in Clark
County with a few hundred thousand
dollars of equity and five rental homes
for sale in Hot Springs Arkansas worth
half a million bucks right now those
homes are subject to a sizable mortgage
I'm sorry he chose to represent himself
and ask the saying goes you meet your
bed now you have to lay in it Clark
County Prosecutors not too sympathetic
about this matter or the other one he
argued about in a rambling handwritten
12-page motion to have his housing
status inside Clark County Detention
Center changed accusing CCDC of quote
cruel and unusual punishment we're
talking about the due process clause
tella says he needs more and better
computer access so he can prepare his
defense at this point is an open
dialogue so we can see about getting
moved to to better accommodations he
also wants out of 24-hour solitary
confinement and says he's not getting
enough time out of his cell we're not
getting one hour out we're getting half
an hour but the prosecutor wasn't having
it this is just what it is to be
incarcerated and neither was the judge
um tell the sheriff how to run his jail
we checked in with Metro who's in charge
of the jail they said Telus is in unit
quote for inmates who have elevated risk
factors and that generally those inmates
do get an hour a day outside their cells
thank you for that Kyle now tell us
we'll be back in court on April 19th on
a separate but related case about access
to information stored on Jeff gearman's
cell phones you